but i will say that technique and a lot
of acting techniques help so much in
writing
what are the steps to developing and
building a character
i have an acting coach who told me this
thing uh i'll just give him a shout out
scott sadida he has this thing called
woefram it's your want obstacle feeling
relationship as if
intention and moment before
that's uh it's a great way to start but
the more uh
the more i guess
pedro style of creating a character i
would say i would say
um
the more pedro style of creating
character in my opinion and my what i
like to do is um i like to listen to a
lot of music
uh that always helps
i like
to
just
i'll read a script and just say it out
loud like a million times just neutral
uh and then
start thinking about other stuff people
are calling me
and uh and life kind of
hugs i guess fiction in that way where
i'll start getting inspiration from
wherever i am in that moment for a
character and just try things out like
and if if i'm ever
kind of in a rut i'll just um
just do something i've never done before
i like doing that a lot when i'm working
on a character
uh like i started skydiving for this
other role that had nothing to do with
skydiving at all uh he was just kind of
like an average guy that was like okay
at skateboarding
and i was like i'm gonna go skydiving um
and it gave me some inspiration for that
and kind of gave me uh
got me out of myself really just getting
yourself out of yourself is the most
important thing for me even if you're
playing a version of yourself because
like i think
uh
that's what attracts me to acting as a
whole of getting to live these different
lives uh so if you can do that in your
normal life that's like even better and
get some inspiration for a character
like
then you're not even working at all
so you really wanna skype skydiving yeah
yeah yeah no i i actually love skydiving
i got halfway through uh my license and
then covet happened ah now i need to
like go redo it but i love skydiving
so you go up in a plane and then you
have like a
like a spotter or a coach or something
that goes down with you or uh oh yeah so
for your
well it's funny actually the first time
you go skydiving it's just
you're not attached to anyone or
anything so that was kind of new when i
showed up i was like
oh so you're like just going already
like
it's been like a six seven hour class
like i mean that's a good amount of time
but like
we're doing it now um and yeah you just
go with uh with another person and he
like kind of gives you hand signals you
know to what you should do straighten
out your legs or you know
widen your arms
um
but that was the coolest experience to
me and that's that's kind of what i
realized as cool about you know
skateboarding or anything like pushing
yourself your boundaries is that
after i got back from skydiving i had an
audition i think the next day i walked
in i did not care at all like
at all i mean i still did the work you
know i cared about the opportunity but
any anxiety that was in the room was
just like
i almost died yesterday
but then i pulled the chute and i didn't
die and now here i am nothing matters
um but uh it's it's a really weirdly
like spiritual thing in that way to like
face your own mortality um
and challenge yourself in that way uh
because i think you realize what's
important in your life really quick and
also
you just take a deep breath and you're
like i'm alive
and then you landed and you said i want
to try this again yeah and then i did it
like six more times seven more times
it was awesome one time the shoot didn't
open
which is really crazy um i mean it
happens it's not super common but like
you do have a backup shoot but it's not
very like good um and also once
the shoot like doesn't open or like gets
caught which was what happened i pulled
it nothing came out and i was like
you're supposed to count to i think six
or seven seconds
and if
nothing
happens after that you're supposed to
pull again it cuts it
and that's a scary thing because you're
like i hope the other one's in there you
know so i was
you know
pulled it nothing happened i was like
okay one two three
four
it comes up the chute pulls
but then it gets twisted and so it's
like this big just a wad of like
parachute you know five six
seven and i'm like pulling the strings
doing all the things you need to do you
know like
uh like eight nine and i'm like all
right i'm waiting too long and i was
just about to like cut it and then like
i pulled it open it you know caught me
it was like
well that was crazy
it was really crazy and so after that
happens you really open up to like other
opportunities like oh please
um but i haven't been in a while and
that's why i think it's important to do
those things on a regular basis maybe it
doesn't need to be skydiving you know
maybe it's like
i don't know uh
calling someone you're really anxious
about calling or you haven't talked to
in years you know
uh whatever it may be for you i think
that's an important thing to like
reset yourself or kind of
um
humble yourself with
have you ever given a talk in front of a
large audience or done
live theater
uh yeah i did some theater in
in high school
but i wasn't i'm kind of jealous of
theater kids like i feel like so many
people in la are theater kids and like i
love shakespeare and all this stuff and
i'm like i don't know it at all like i
yeah
i i don't even really watch so much
theater it's not that i don't like it
but it's just like i like movies um
uh like birdman yeah yeah yeah yeah
watching a movie about theater i'm there
um
but uh but yeah it's a different muscle
for sure i i do like it for that reason
um but i also uh don't get to
like see pretty images and cuts and
sound design as as much in theater as
you do in movies um and that's when i
really realized i'm a filmmaker when i
was like oh but in theater you don't get
to like cut two or like
go back i mean there's like
people do some crazy things in theater
but it's not the same you know what i
mean so
yeah that's why i like movies i mean tv
shows are cool too but i really like
movies
that's true because tv shows some of
them are filmed in front of a live
audience so you could oh that's true
yeah there's some sitcoms right i just
met some other guy on a movie i was
doing who is like the king at that he
was like the funniest guy ever and i was
like that's why
you're used to like playing for the
camera you know and then playing for the
audience you know we're like talking
like in a group of people i'm like
you're not only entertaining me you're
also entertaining like the six other
people around here and i'm like
i admire that i'm gonna go take a photo
of this like bush over here and put
music behind it
tell me again the woe moment
so it's uh called the woe frame and this
is a hundred percent scott sedito's
technique uh he's he's awesome there's
lots of different variants of it but he
teaches you woeframe which is your want
in the scene what do you want the scene
your obstacle in the scene what can't
you get the feelings you're feeling
throughout the scene they may change the
relationship you have with the
characters you're in the scene with
you're as if
which is like what how is this similar
to a moment in my life
uh your intentions you can go line by
line i intend to uh punish you or
whatever it may be
and then your moment before so that's
the moment before the scene even happens
what was your character doing
and to me
that was like my like freshman year and
acting like oh
now i know how to act like i had taken
many classes before that but it was a
good just jump start to be like when in
doubt like you have that
now i make up all my own stuff
but every once in a while go back and be
like
you know pick little techniques like
that out from from that technique wow
frame woah for your life
shout out to scott
yeah shout out to scott awesome
were there moments do you think that you
incorporated that into i mean it sounds
like with every role it's just like in
you but but for my dead dad were there
moments where you're like you know what
i really have to go back to that maybe
it was too personal or whatever it was
yeah i think so i think so it's funny
because i never i never consciously do
it anymore like i never like
scott always makes you write it on the
side of your paper you know and like
write it out which is good for like the
memory just to
write you know um but
i'll always subconsciously do it like if
i'm like oh even i just said i don't use
it i'm like doing it all the time you
know just without ever thinking about it
you know but i will say that technique
and a lot of acting techniques help so
much in writing i learned so much about
writing by being an acting class there
was probably like a year or two
yeah maybe two years or at least the
solid year where i was like consciously
in acting class like
you know working my muscle as an actor
sure but also
literally just translating everything to
like how i could use that in the script
how i could
reverse engineer that from a performer's
standpoint and be like okay what is the
moment before the scene what is the
what is the want in this thing the scene
doesn't have any want but should we even
have this scene in the movie probably
not there's nothing happening here you
know
so it's been super helpful
being an actor and
and using those acting powers on writing
in a way